hello everyone I'm Jeff Brock I'm the
dean of the School of Engineering and
applied science we're going by the
moniker Yale engineering just to drive
the point home um this is the dean's
invited speaker series which I'm really
pleased to inaugurate we had the idea
that it would be a good way to announce
our new strategy to the community by
inviting um really Affiliates friends
from industry that have taken their Yale
experience in some way and turned it
into a bright uh illustrious career in
industry in one way or another um and
our visitor today Katherine gini is an
the embodiment of this uh she has become
a good friend over a few meetings we
have some commonalities in our Yale
experience um like me she met her future
spouse while engaged in an
extracurricular activity in her case the
Y Herald in my case I was uh
Moonlighting in a James Joyce
seminar uh so be careful which
extracurricular activities you choose
you may end up reliving them throughout
the rest of your life um so so I'm I'm
also really excited to have you hear
about her story her trajectory through
her time uh working in industry and the
different twists and turns that taken
but on a on a somewhat lighter note I'll
just mention she has uh recently
been U mentioned in as you know some top
10 ranking in a list of 100 most
influential women that included Taylor
Swift Simone biles
Beyonce and who's the other
one yeah anyway so we're in the presence
of some celebrity here and uh you know
the the School of Engineering and
applied science um and our applied
physics department in particular thank
you vid vids for joining us uh has uh
you know generates a lot of celebrity in
the world and and and Katherine is among
them so we're very pleased to welcome
her she's going to give about 30 minutes
of uh presentation and and talk about
her trajectory and then we'll have
plenty of time for some Q&A which uh I'm
happy to host so welcome C and thank you
for
coming hi everyone thank you so much um
it's really great to be here I graduated
in 1994 which sounds like a really
really long time ago I'm sure to all of
you um I was in Morse I was an applied
physics major and um I really have
wonderful memories of my time here at
Yale so it's always nice to come back
and I'm going to share with you a few
things today I have let's see
um three main topics and and really this
is meant to be sort of a teaser of
topics that I'm more than happy to talk
about so when we get to the Q&A if
there's anything that you'd like to hear
more about or ask me questions then um
I'm happy to happy to discuss but I
wanted to first talk a little bit about
my career what did I do when I left Yale
and how did that transpire into a series
of different opportunities I think Riel
really prepared me well but I had no
idea where I would go next and I will
tell you a little bit about how that
played out then talk a bit about
technology and transformation and my
role at IBM I spent 24 years in
different capacities largely trying to
drive Innovation and transformation
leveraging technology and I'll give you
a little bit of a feel for what that has
looked like for me and then I want to
spend a few minutes talking about the
other aspects of being a leader
particularly a leader in the technology
industry um it would be great if we
could only talk about science
engineering but in reality that's fun
and important but not sufficient to
really drive impact and so I think there
are a lot of other aspects of leadership
leading teams driving execution managing
crises and others that I learned on the
job and I think there's a real
opportunity to think through some of
that perhaps ahead of time and be better
prepared than I was as I got into some
of these
experiences so let's start with a career
first um
I I imagine some of you think of um a
career ladder or some idea of some long
range plan I always admired those people
who were really clear about what they
wanted to do when they grew up and I
never knew in fact while I was an
applied mid physics major if you had
caught me in my first or second year
here at Yale I probably would have told
you that maybe I was going to be a
political science major or an Italian
major or art history or maybe I wanted
to go into journalism or who who knows
all sorts of things and I ended up
focusing on Applied Physics because it
was hard and I liked solving hard
problems and I liked figuring things out
I had um my grandfather was a math
teacher here in New Haven taught at the
public schools Hill House High School
for many many years and for as long as I
can remember as a kid he thought doing
math was the best thing ever and he made
me think that math as a tool for solving
problems was was um was fun and so when
I got to actually apply it to solving
problems like in physics I thought that
was fun too so after I got my degree in
Applied Physics um well actually before
I got my degree I actually got a chance
to work as an intern at hulet Packard
out in California and this was summer of
1993 so sort of the Heyday of Silicon
Valley and um a professor here uh Robert
wheeler who I think is now retired but
he connected me to one of his former
students who was working at HP and
that's how I ventured out across the
country and spent the summer working in
industry in the in the tech world you
know taking measurements in a lab
writing code trying to figure out what
you do with an Applied Physics degree in
the real world but what an experience
being in Silicon Valley and I decided to
go back so I ended up going to graduate
school at Stanford down the road from HP
in Palo Alo California and being a part
of the Silicon Valley Community at that
time was really stimulating I went back
to HP for another summer I did an
internship at Advanced Micro Devices or
AMD who is now a tremendous leader in in
the industry they were they were playing
second P at the time to Intel and
semiconductor technology and
Manufacturing but I got a chance to see
what it was like to take some of this
science that I learned in school and
actually apply it in the real world as a
a graduate student I worked with a
professor named Calvin quate um he was
about my grandfather's age I was among
the very last of the students he had he
looked like Einstein big white crazy
hair he was the co-inventor of the
acoustic M microscope and the atomic
Force microscope or AFM that some of you
may know about and at the time everyone
was talking about the end of silicon
scaling Mo's law that you wouldn't be
able to pattern using light and using
traditional op IAL lithography any
longer to shrink the transistors and
scale the microchips and therefore we
wouldn't get faster computers we
wouldn't be able to have better
electronics and there's lots of worry at
the time about this world has changed
and we still have faster computers and
Powerful cell phones at the time
everyone was thinking about how can you
scale the way how small something you
can pattern how do you make better
transistors that can actually turn off
when they get to the dimensions around
uh a few atoms thick and so that was
what I did and I got to get in a lab
build transistors use these scanning
probes to do parallel patterning emit
electrons from a probe build transistors
build chips test them so it was a
hugely interesting experience right
really trying to learn how to actually
build things and and and demonstrate
value that the industry was looking for
so when I finished my degree I came
directly to IBM and then I spent the
next 24 years at IBM so a long time but
doing so many different things I started
doing technical research so my first six
or so years I was working in a lab and I
was taking some of that experience I had
in graduate school and doing internships
and actually applying it to what IBM did
which was to actually build
semiconductor technology for their
systems business building
microprocessors building all the chips
that were in the the competing game
stations the Nintendo chip the Sony the
the Microsoft Xbox chip and so on they
needed to have high performance uh
technology to to deliver that and so I
first was in the research lab
experimenting with new transistor
designs new structures new materials and
then I moved into the development space
which is how do you get these to yield
reliably how can you build them at scale
and ensure that we have a a business
that is going to be uh productive and
then I got a chance to move around the
company outside of that semiconductor
and research development space because I
wanted to know what the rest of IBM did
and I'm going to tell you all a little
bit about IBM because I didn't know all
I knew was this little research world
because as a graduate student i' had
read papers
from researchers at IBM and I thought I
want to do that but I didn't really know
what the rest of the company did so I
deliberately moved outside the research
division got a chance to work in
development of our microprocessor design
I was managing a large Global team
designing microprocessors again I'm not
a circuit designer but I was leading a
team on that moved into product
management how do we launch net new
products we wanted to bring a technology
the Mainframe technology had been around
for 50 years at that point we wanted to
bring that technology known for Reliable
secure highly
available Computing we wanted to bring
that to new workloads and to new clients
that had never used a Mainframe before
how do you do that well we actually
leveraged The open- Source operating
system Linux on the Mainframe technology
we l launched a new brand we called
Linux one we went out and talked to
clients and said how do we get you to
use this product what is inhibiting you
is it skills is it user experience is it
functionality performance latency Etc so
bringing that back and then working with
our development teams to design the next
generation of that product so completely
different type type of experience for me
how do you price it how do you go to
market where is the product Market fit
who is the competition it's a completely
different set of questions and and
answers and then I came back to the
research division after having been
outside of that for almost a dozen years
and I worked as the Chief Operating
Officer for the research division IBM
research has 3,000 researchers largely
PhD mostly doing very deep technical
work some exploratory more academic life
like and some very closely collaborating
with our development teams and that
whole Spectrum I've been around for 75
years This research division but we were
worried about going the way of bell labs
and other Industrial Research
organizations that aren't around anymore
and so my role as the COO was how do you
make sure we're relevant how do we
increase the impact but not lose that
very special capability that was able to
have Nobel Prize winners and to have
very very high recognition for the
innovation in the research Division and
then I spent the last two and a half
years as IBM's CIO which is the Chief
Information officer and I'll tell you a
little bit about what that role is
because again I didn't really know I
didn't really know what the role was all
about and I and I it's different in
different organizations but suffice it
to say large
organization big set of deliverables at
the company was relying on and I got a
chance to use a lot of the skills I had
developed over the course of my career
to figure out how do you solve both
technical problems but also some of the
execution and Leadership and other
aspects of leading in Innovation when
you have um high stakes because at that
point all IBM employees and all IBM
clients were then relying on the CIO
team to deliver the it and the
capabilities to do their
jobs so so if I can go forward here um
let me just tell you real briefly about
IBM so it was founded in 1911 so it's
been around a very very long time and
it's changed a lot you see at the bottom
of the chart some of the things it's
known for from Punch Cards to um
Computing machines helping to land uh
people on the moon uh certainly well
known for that um Watson beating
Jeopardy in 2011 was was a proud moment
I started to understand what natural
language processing and uh question
answering systems could do and today the
the flagship product from IBM is called
Watson X and you may have seen some
advertising about that recently but
what's interesting when I'll tell you a
little about the it or the CIO role is
the size and scale of the company there
are 280,000 employees at IBM it's like
the size of a small country but it does
business in 170 plus countries of the
world which means you have to deal with
different different cultures languages
regulatory requirements laws
Etc and time zones when you're managing
and and supporting that
community and then the size and scale of
the business it's about a $60 billion
Revenue annually and it has three main
portions of the business it still has
what's Legacy infrastructure Hardware
business delivering systems was largely
what I had started in that space it has
a very growing software portion of the
business and the big piece of that was
the acquisition of the company Red Hat
it's known for open source enterprise
software and then there's a Consulting
business so technology and business
services that IBM supports as
well and so as the
CIO I was the global person and
organization responsible for delivering
it to that
IBM community so large large number of
people lots of geographic spread and
working with clients in all these
different Industries so this is a quick
picture of what the CIO organization and
IBM is responsible for and I'll point
you to this middle section it's called
digital workplace Solutions it's mostly
what people associate with it or a CIO
you get your workstation you get your
laptop mobile device get on the
internet um I can get it help or support
so those and and those certainly are the
things one of some of the things that
that I and the team was responsible for
but what little did I know the stuff on
top the business applications that
actually run the company were actually
the line share of the investment and the
complexity that we were responsible for
so running payroll systems and
procurement and real estate and uh
supply chain all the HR systems Etc
Finance how do you close the books all
these applications over 4,000 Enterprise
applications that we needed to run IBM
successfully need to be reliable secure
scalable that when a client has an issue
they can get in touch with and get
response times
immediately how do you modernize that
environment how do we take advantage of
new technologies how do we improve the
experience for our employees and for our
clients how we transform this and reduce
how much we're spending while doing that
so that was the sort Challenge and get
getting our arms around that and
maintaining it and then of course we're
responsible for the infrastructure on
which that is all
run and because IBM is an IT company I
wanted to be an early adopter of all
IBM's technology right so just as we
develop a new server system or a new
piece of software or we have a way of
partnering with a set of strategic
Technologies in the industry I wanted to
be the very first to use that technology
so that we could demonstrate the value
if it can work for IBM at our scale it
can work for any one of IBM's clients
and then we can also provide feedback to
our development and our product teams to
make it better so that IBM could grow as
a business so we had both the
responsibilities for at the back office
to support the company but also to be
out there a Leading Edge to make sure
that we're taking advantage of IBM's
technology because you can imagine if
you go to a customer and you say IBM
we're focused on hypercloud and AI
what's the next we've got this great
stuff use CIO because IBM actually sells
to cios in the industry of Banks and
Retail companies and so on we've got a
solution for
you what do you think the first thing
that they're going to ask
is do you use it yourself does it work
for you and if the answer is no we lose
all of our credibility and so is really
important that we be out there in front
means we're taking risk that means we're
being an early adopter and actually C
creating all right so I want to talk a
little bit about technology I'll just
let you read this um little cartoon it's
one of my
favorites everyone's so excited about
chat PT and it's wonderful I mean how
exciting that we all have ai in our
hands today it really is but that's not
the same as applying AI or any
technology to large scale Enterprise
environments because I have to worry
about data privacy and confidentiality
to worry about scale and repeatability
is it trustworthy what data was it
trained on can I explain the result and
so I want to use all of the Technologies
and the very best there is but I need to
be very thoughtful and responsible about
the applications of that technology and
it's not technology and Innovation just
for technology and Innovation sake it's
about what problems are we solving and
what value are are we delivering so I
always like to start with what what are
the issues or what are the concerns on
the minds of of Business Leaders in an
Enterprise and so here are some there
are of course many more but huge
pressure at an Enterprise level and I
saw this at IBM and I saw this in our
clients right most of our clients are
coming to a company like IBM saying
helping us help us reinvent ourselves
using technology new business models new
ways of going to Market new ways of
developing products
productivity is the word of the year of
the decade perhaps most CI CEOs so the
leaders of these companies are telling
us that what they care about is
productivity what that usually
translates into how can I be more
efficient and effective how can I get my
Workforce to get more output for a given
input how do I get more things done so
Ai and Technologies are certain a piece
of that but it's also new ways of
working the hybrid and remote working
model model its labor shortages its
skill shifts it's a huge focus and
Technology can play a key role cyber
security is a huge concern massive
number and frequency and severity of
cyber attacks today that are very very
costly not just in dollars but
reputational cost and time and business
value so we need to protect against that
sustainability has become top of mind um
probably should have been for a very
long time but it now finally is clear
that all of us and businesses are
playing a role in impacting our climate
and we need to take responsibility for
being very very thoughtful and
technology is both a
contributor as well as a potential
solution in how do we address some of
the pressing CH challenges around
sustainability geopolitical risks this
is rising threats this is supply chain
uh vulnerabilities and much more and
finally public health and we've just
been through a pandemic but it's not
only infection ious diseases it's mental
health and it's so many other aspects of
Public Health care about that at an
Enterprise level because it's our
employees it's our clients Society at
large and so if if you think about these
are a set of the problems that we we see
in front of us every single day
technology and Innovation can play a
role in addressing this but it's not
just about how many applications of AI
do you have interesting but more
important about the so what what are you
doing with it that's meaningful and
impactful to the to the company and to
the
organization so I'll highlight just
three technologies that I think are
important today there of course are many
many more and these are in uh different
levels of maturity I'd say hybrid cloud
or cloud computing today is very much uh
mature and available set of capabilities
but still in its infancy in terms of
widescale adoption and by that we
largely mean you know the Legacy world
was all these distributed data centers
all over the world when I took on the
job of CIO there were 74 different data
centers where IBM was running workload
for our internal use all over the world
I mean I think about it I how do I get
my arms around that where where is
everything running how do I secure it
how do I think about the sustainability
what what's the carbon footprint of all
that how do I manage latency and
performance and user experience how do I
modernize something that is that
fragmented and so by moving to a true
hybrid cloud and by that we mean a
combination of on Prem private and
public Cloud not one public cloud answer
only because that typically locks you
into a solution that may not be any
better than you were before but having
some flexibility to be able to move
workloads across different environments
if I maybe have a change in the
requirement from a client or from an
employee I want to be able ble to have
more flexibility which I didn't have in
the old Legacy environments we've moved
a huge amount of IBM's workload into
this more flexible environment and we're
seeing tremendous benefits in terms of
how quickly we can deploy applications
how much money we save and frankly the
carbon footprint piece as well AI I mean
this is the hottest topic today I'm sure
everybody here is talking about it
thinking about it using it um which is
which is great as I said it's really
about the responsible use of that
technology so we have had we have a
number of Enterprise applications in
particular we've used robotic process
automation or RPA to automate manual
tasks this isn't about displacing
workers it's actually about getting off
of their their plates a lot of the more
mundane tasks and freeing their time and
energy up to do higher value work which
is important and needed and frankly
valued by by our employees as well um we
had a number of applications like
automating h Char and it support using
AI so you don't have to wait on a call
center and worrying about what hours or
is there someone there and we're used to
this sorry for the in the consumer world
but many Enterprises don't have it
because they worry about security and
privacy and many of their aspects but uh
at this point if I want to transfer an
employee at IBM or do a salary increase
or do a whole host of other HR tasks
they can almost exclusively be done
through digital assistant chatbot AI
technology can be done 24 hours a day it
can be done with inline language
translation if you're in a part of the
world and you don't speak English you're
not comfortable it gives you a lot more
flexibility and we just applied uh some
very similar technology to providing
that it support and Quantum Computing so
Yale also is very um very big in this
space IBM has invested this is um this
is what we have today but I think
there's still opportunity very much
opportunity into the future on how do we
leverage uh new Computing technology not
to take over not to replace traditional
classical Computing but to be able to
solve some problems that simply can't be
solved in with the technology that we
have today it's very exciting um the the
the work that IBM around in
collaboration with a number of Partners
is advancing this capability um very
fast and we're seeing that now people
can actually solve some really
interesting problems starting to see
Quantum advantage number this is 433
cubits or or bits that are available for
uh Quantum computation today with a
commitment by the end of the year will
be a thousand and before long tens of
thousands I mean that's a t i I honestly
truly didn't think that that was going
to be possible in our life time it's an
amazing level of progress but it's
interesting on the technology but then
what do you do with it so the
applications the use cases in quantum
chemistry and finance and optimization
are really compelling and the network of
universities startups and large Fortune
500 companies that are starting to
explore what Quantum Computing might do
for them it's very exciting there's also
the The Fear Factor which is oh gosh
when we have large-scale Quantum
Computing this will be able to break
traditional public key cryptography and
that's true but there are new
cryptographic algorithms like Lattis
cryptography that are robust against
large scale Quantum Computing but then
that takes us back to our our cyber
security focus and what do we do to make
sure that we're really prepared for
Quantum Computing take advantage of it
but we also protect against some of the
uh risks that that any technology
brings all right and then my last
section is about leadership and one of
my favorite cartoons here because I
think it's so telling most people think
oh great you're the CIO so you just tell
everybody what to
do that must be pretty straightforward
right Jeff you're the dean right you
just get to tell everybody what to do
right
really um and that would that would be
nice but the reality is and you all know
this um leadership is messy and it's
complicated and it's challenging in in
in many ways and so I thought I would
highlight some of the aspects of leading
whether you're leading an IT team or
product development organization or
research Community or launching net new
products that you need to think about
that are outside of the bits and bites
outside of the science but are
critically important to success so the
first is when you're driving these
projects there's a whole host of things
that we do as leaders that need to be
thoughtful about what is what does
success look like what are we really
trying to achieve and how will we know
we're making the necessary progress to
deliver so there's the strategy aspect
the project planning the budgeting the
prioritization what guard rails do you
have in
place what metrics and measurements what
governance do we have and this stuff is
not all that straightforward depends a
lot on the team and the priorities and
how but hugely important to success and
again it doesn't it almost doesn't
matter what you're what you're trying to
do you're trying to deliver a new
mainframe system to the market you're
developing Quantum Computing you're
trying to create an innovation through
Ai and delivering it to 280,000 IBM
employees you have to be clear on what
does success look like and how do you
ensure that you can deliver on that
commitment but there are always risks
always so how are you thoughtful and
proactive about identifying what those
risks are and how do you minimize those
risks but also prepare for the
eventualities of when something goes
wrong because it always does right um
have all sorts of crises stories that I
could tell but I will I will tell you
one that will probably make you laugh um
we we moved to a new mail system a
couple years ago and as the CIO was one
of the things that I was responsible for
one of many things and it didn't
shouldn't and didn't didn't think it
would raise to the top level of my focus
and attention but when you move move
280,000 employees to new mail system and
the system goes down and they can't
access their email for upwards of two
weeks that's a crisis made the paper I
had to record all sorts of
communications to the entire Global
Community to talk to our CEO on a daily
basis we had to put an action plan what
wasn't something we could just switch a
button and be back there were technical
challenges there were leadership
challenges there were communication
challenges there was root cause analysis
that we needed to understand and then
once we got ourselves out of that crisis
we needed to make sure that we were
clear how we would prevent anything like
that from happening again so how do you
learn from that experience and not just
Catherine learning or not just the
leader of the project learning but the
organization at large right how do you
help the organization to be better for
any of the issues and
concerns and then perhaps the most
important thing and if I if I remember
one thing from my my story it's it's all
about the people because you can do
great science and you can have
interesting project plans and crisis
management uh
proposals but it's all about the people
that you have to get your projects done
and to inspire and to drive Innovation
and to do delivery and those people it
it they
require handholding and support and
inspiration and leadership in order for
them to be most effective how do you
build effective teams do you build a
multidisiplinary set of capabilities
people with different expertise who
understand the different cultures and
geographies and laws and disciplines and
how do you help them to work together
effectively if they have these different
perspectives and experiences how do you
reward or incent the right Behavior how
do you provide performance feedback
effectively coaching and you manage your
team effectively all of this is sort of
not taught in school I would say but so
important to the success of any of these
projects in my experience what we tend
to not not recognize or even prioritize
enough even from those of us who have
risen through the ranks who have a PhD
and vice president experience and
leading large
organizations because I'll tell you the
the first time I had a 500 person team
and we're trying to build a
microprocessor and you have billions of
billions of transistors that all need to
be connected together in a way that you
can tape this out on a specific date 18
months from
now well now you have the complexity of
managing that schedule you have the
technical hurdles that need to get done
how you can have the right latency and
and performance and so on you have the
Personnel aspects do I have the right
skills and capability
roles and responsibilities who's going
to be making the decisions what happens
when all of a sudden six months in
there's a new opportunity or challenge
there's a competitive issue there's a
technical issue you have to have these
kinds of experiences and skills in your
pocket so you can pull them out and
respond and if you don't you learn on
the job and you find mentors and you
find others who can help you to be
effective but for sure that you don't
you don't do the things that that I've
been talking about out with um with
science or with engineering alone it's
super important I think the credibility
of understanding the science and
engineering to many of these leadership
positions has been very important for me
but to couple that with some of these
other aspects of leading executing and
driving teams and the inspiration part
because in the end you're going to have
hard things there be hard days and and
projects and challenges but you need to
have the team with you right who are
excited and about coming in every day
and working as partners to try to solve
these problems that goes a a hugely long
way into the overall
success so the very last chart before we
open it up for questions um you've heard
about a lot of things that I like to
talk about I decided a few years ago
during coid we were all stuck at home
that I would uh start a blog and write
about some of these topics whether it's
leadership and work life balance and
what it looks like to be a woman in a
largely male-dominated Hardware
technology space or science and
Innovation Etc and um one of my favorite
things is when someone will say oh I
read that and I agree or I disagree or I
had a similar experience or I'm also
struggling with that or my husband also
does the laundry or whatever the story
happens to be so it's been a great
conversation starter and um as as jefff
said my husband also went to Yale so he
happens to be um wearing a Yale shirt in
this picture um he was in silon right
right near here and um we met working on
the Yale har
uh so we've got a science and he's a
he's a social studies teacher and so we
got different different sides of the
brain and we have three children two in
college one in middle school and um it's
been an adventure right lots of lots of
fun lots of learning and my you know my
favorite thing about being in the
technology space is I said it's hard but
it also it's always there's always
something new to learn there's always
something new to learn about the Science
and Technology but also in all those
other aspects of leading projects and
driving execution and it's it's been a
it's been a wild ride for me I've got
got a chance to learn over over many
many years and I look forward to
learning more going forward so with that
I will open it
up great thank you so much cther okay
great we get some seats I also do the
laundry by the way just uh fold this
Clos
um so I want to open it up for questions
but I have a couple questions of my own
if I may um the first is you know
Yale prepares us in various ways for
various things what would you say is the
thing you remember about your Yale
experience that has helped you the most
and what do you wish you had learned
here interesting question that they
missed we missed
um so I the one of the most pivotal
experiences I had was was as a leader on
the Y Herald or the weekly newspaper and
um not just because I met my husband
although that was also pivotal but um
being in a leadership role with people
who didn't have to you know weren't
getting paid right nobody had a job and
was really worrying about so much on
their their resume but it was because
people felt like they wanted to be a
part of the team and that they felt
valued and that we all made it fun but
we also
deeply about the quality of the output
and I think that experience perhaps more
than anything else is something that I
took forward into other leadership roles
that I had and so that's something I I
absolutely remember and just working
with brilliant people and being in a
community of of smart and motivated
ambitious but collaborative people
that's something I really valued in my
time at Yale and I've looked for and and
one of the things about IBM is you're
working with people who are deeply smart
and motivated and not so different
perhaps in the community here so
absolutely have enjoyed that what do I
wish um so I learned so much from a from
a technical perspective in the Applied
Physics Applied Physics was and I think
still is a fairly small department and I
really I was deliberate about that and I
stayed in an applied physics program in
graduate school as well because I liked
that basic science but also applying it
to to real world problems I I saw
thought the industry experience and
reaching out I would say I didn't feel
like there was a lot of I I got lucky
that I have a professor who re you know
connected me to somebody but I think the
opportunity to learn about what kind of
jobs and what kind of opportunities
exist out there in the world so like
what you're doing and inviting people in
to share that I think that's that's
great I didn't feel like I had a lot of
that when I was here and I couldn't
really imagine what life would be like
after and I so I just kept going and
then work out yeah this is a it's a True
Unicorn here the Applied Physics major I
don't know there how many Applied
Physics majors are there in the anyone
oh there we go okay okay great um yeah I
mean that's that's really interesting
so you know we wrestle and the
institution wrestles I think with the
question of the kinds of how how much we
should broaden the training of
undergraduates to include the things
that you mentioned as these really key
skills that you developing kind of on
the job right so do you have a sense of
you know if we were to think about new
ways to develop the curriculum that
would prepare people for some of the
things you didn't learn here but maybe
wish you could have um is there is there
kind of a list of key things that you
would suggest we think about I think
there are um I think there are
Frameworks and models for some of the
things that I've talked about
um and I think there's an opportunity to
both learn about them sort of the book
learning of it but also to practice it
and so I know you have you have
experiential courses leading teams and
projects I'd say there's very little of
um having a hard problem and going off
and thinking about that by yourself in a
room that I've experienced as u in the
professional World a lot of this is
team-based learning it's figuring things
out together it's taking advantage of
all these different perspectives so I
think finding ways to get that
experience while you're a student so it
doesn't feel so foreign when you get
into the into the Working
World yeah yeah I agree um and then I
guess I have one more and then I'm going
to open it up so you know we are really
eager to bring kind of like this you
know bring some of the knowledge and
experience and even the sort of
technology and Technology awareness that
exists in Industry into how we think
about teaching our students how we think
about collaborating in terms of our
research Labs what do you see as the
sort of positives of that but also some
of the pitfalls that universities need
to be aware of as we sort of embrace
technology that exists in
Industry yeah I I think there's huge
value of bringing it in and making it
relevant and seeing kind of this real
life tangible what's going on and how do
you get your arms around it but I think
the pitfall is you know you don't want
to you want to get so enamored with one
particular technology right chat
gptx is not going to be the end all be
all right for the rest of your careers
it's more about how do you understand
the um what led to that Innovation what
are the key uh components of it how do
you use how do you understand when new
technology emerges how do you take
advantage of it because there'll be you
know next year five years from now 10
years from now it will be something else
and so it it's really I think it's
important to be relevant and to be
connect connected but not to get so
enamored by whatever it is today because
the technology in the business world is
changing so fast it will certainly be
different as you as you
progress good okay any questions from
the
audience uh yeah right here sure oh we
have a m because there you go um when
you made the transition from a sort of
research sort of PhD role to a more busy
role
I guess there were a lot of skills as
you sort of said that you sort of maybe
didn't have or had to learn to what
extent did you feel like you had to be
really proactive about going out and
learning those versus really learning
them on the job or just sort of like
using the sort of experiences to guide
you I did a lot of learning on the job I
would say and I think that is pretty
typical certainly at IBM I can't speak
to every other company but I think in
Tech that's pretty typical um in
technology even people outside of say
the research and development we don't
have a huge number of pure sort of MBA
business management leaders in fact the
the CEO of IBM is a PhD electrical
engineer right not an MBA not a I mean
he's a super smart businessman but his
Technical Training is in engineering and
and that's sort of the ethos of the
company and and so it wasn't like had to
go get an MBA or I had and I took
various classes and I found value in in
that but much of that was learned on the
job and in fact my first management role
the first time I was leading a team of
people and that had to do performance
reviews and be responsible for their
success um how as is typical you get
promoted into those positions because
you're good at your other job which I
this is something every every company
out there does and it's typically
mistake St but hey you're really good at
being a technical contributor will make
you a manager and all of a sudden you
have people in management positions who
have no business being in management
positions because they may not actually
be that good at the guidance of a team
or the leadership of a team they may be
just really really good individual
contributors now some grow into it right
some actually you know embrace it and
want but others don't and then that's a
disservice to the people in their
organization right they just suddenly
now have somebody that is looking for
the power the so for me when I got that
first leadership position I was actually
super excited about it I wanted that and
I valued that but I also knew that I
didn't have the experience I suddenly I
was managing people who
had many many more years of experience
than I did who um had uh you know diff
sometimes difficult to manage right
especially the in the research Community
notoriously sort of independent-minded
as you can imagine um um and I didn't
feel like the role of the manager or my
role was particularly valued even
amongst the leadership in research that
like I was disappointed by that I said
this is really important I want to do a
great job at this and they're like yeah
yeah yeah just keep doing your research
that was that was how I felt I don't
think that was actually accurate that's
how I felt when I moved into other parts
of IBM particularly into development
teams the role of the manager it was
super important because suddenly you
couldn't get a project done you can
deliver our chip design on schedule
keeping your team
motivated if you didn't have managers
who were really equipped to lead these
teams effectively but also have the
technical credibility that the the team
would listen and so I really liked being
a manager in the development
organization because suddenly that role
was really important and I was playing
not only a people management role but
also a project management role so
responsible for the delivery of the
project and I found that really
rewarding yeah uh either way yeah circle
around did you ever experience impostor
syndrome and if you did um how did you
deal with that yeah great question so
impostor syndrome for those who haven't
heard of it is uh very common that um
people feel like well I I'm not
deserving I I why am I in this position
so yes most of us in in leadership
position s have um particularly when I
became the IBM CIO so suddenly I was in
a seite position at the
company and I
thought what why me right why am I in
this role do I deserve to be here so and
it's very natural right it's I think
many of us and it's particularly common
among women um question whether you are
deserving or whether you're
um a up to the task um I think the the
biggest advice I have is that you're in
it for a reason right no nobody nobody
gives you a job like this
for to be nice hey Jeff wouldn't it be
nice it doesn't happen it just doesn't
happen it's too important to the
business to the company it is not
nobody's getting token jobs um so you
got to bolster your confidence a little
bit to say of course it's deserved but
then you have to earn it to right so for
me it's about okay get over that but
then what do what do what do I need to
do to make sure that I can do a great
job right what do I need to be effective
and it doesn't mean knowing everything
or being the smartest in the room or
knowing all aspect I showed you that CIO
portfolio look I took the job I didn't
even know that right I literally didn't
know what I was getting into i' been in
many other parts of the
company but the reason why our CEO
decided to put me in the role suddenly
they had somebody who had developed
products who knew the IBM organization
who understood how to lead large
teams and drive Innovation so I was
coming with a different set of
experiences than my predecessor and
others who had been in that space before
and I was focused on how do I bring that
how do I bring that value that I was
selected for but also how do I learn how
do I surround myself with people who can
fill in some of those gaps and have
expertise where I don't and not be
afraid to ask a lot of questions I ask a
lot of questions and it's not because
I'm trying to test somebody else but
because I genuinely am curious and I
need to know and I want us to know
explore and figure things out together
so I think those are all sort of
techniques but it's um It's Not Unusual
I was just telling jefff I just got
appointed to a a my first public company
corporate board and I said well this
board is so impressive impressive there
are there are Nobel Prize winners and
there are people who have been leading
all the and my first reaction is why why
do they want me on and and so I still
have it I still have it and I think it's
only natural I think it's good that you
can you know continue to be somewhat
humble and not think that you're
deserving of everything um on the other
hand kind of have to straighten your
spine and say I can do this and I'll add
value and let me figure out how to ask a
lot of questions and learn but also
figure out what my unique value ad is
and and lean into
that yeah thank you than hi uh it's
related to the question about transition
from research to uh management and
business jobs I guess apart from skills
that are to be learned what can you
recommend on us to prepare for it like
mentally is there a mindset change that
because I guess I'm a PhD student and as
a PhD student it's a lot of time is to
make make things work right on the edge
and I I take fun of that but that's
probably not the correct spirit in
management so when I feel that things
can be done better but there's
compromise to make when you feel this
way do you feel uncomfortable and do you
think there's a mindset change that we
can prepare ourselves yeah that's a
great question
um yeah it's it's it certainly is
different when you're when you're doing
research you know in in a university or
even in the research community at a
company like IBM um there's a bit of a
luxury in that you're you're not looking
necessarily at trying to build
repeatable products you're not looking
at trying to scale a solution you're
trying to typically you know Drive
Innovation invent demonstrate something
is possible and boy that is exciting
right something that's never been done
before you're trying to show for the
first time and to demonstrate that value
so there's it's so there's so much great
experience from that and not everybody
can do it obviously there are people who
just they're not programmed that way
they're not they're not as excited by
this this invention and this Innovation
and this brand newness um but it is
different when you move into a space
where um suddenly you're trying to
deliver something at scale where
repeatability and reliability and
performance and security and privacy
like all these Things become Paramount
and even if you have something that's
been demonstrated it's amazing it may
not have any place over here and that's
true right so so I think one of the
interesting things for me when I went
back to the research division after
having been outside it for quite some
time I had a completely different
mindset than I had before so now I'm
saying why are we doing this some in
some cases not everything like this is
never going to work right and you know I
had to check that too
because part of the role of of research
is to explore avenues that may or not
may not be commercially viable so that
that's okay that some portion of the
portfolio is pushing the envelope we
can't always know where it will go so
you don't want to predispose or limit or
stop doing things just because there's
risk but there has to be a spectrum and
that was one of the things that I was
focused on in research is to look at a
portfolio of projects some some that are
in this riskier element which is okay to
not always see the commercial viability
in the early days and some that have a
lower risk and more alignment to the
product portfolio commercialization and
so on and as long as you're deliberate
about that and you acknowledge it and
you're cleare eyed I think that's fine
but there's a difference and if you do
everything over here I don't think I
don't think the community I don't think
a industrial research lab Will Survive
if everything is so far a field that
they're shot in the dark and super high
risk but if everything in research is so
close to product that it's a guaranteed
you know home run then you're probably
just an extension of the development
team and it's probably not truly the the
the the role that a research
organization needs to play so that
Spectrum or portfolio I think is really
important great we have time for one
more there you go y
uh so I I was curious since you've been
at IBM I guess 24 years and it seems
relatively rare that maybe someone would
stay at one spot for so long especially
in in tech one did you ever consider
leaving IBM and were there different
points like in your career where you
really kind of checked in with yourself
or consulted mentors or even uh just how
you thought about kind of reaffirming
the decision to to stay and what value
you might have actually derived from
actually being in one one spot instead
of moving around yeah really good
question um it turns out that there are
um not only a few people at IBM who stay
20 25 30 40 years at the company so it's
not it's not that unusual um although
you know at large you know like the
average tenure for most people in jobs
is like four years in the country right
now so it certainly is strange on that
on that side um if I were doing the same
thing for 20 four years I would have
gotten bored and left immediately so the
nice thing about a company like IBM it's
so big it has so many different aspects
to the company that I had the pleasure
of having like a dozen different jobs
over the course of 24 years so that was
a real benefit to me and why because I
had a network of people that I had
worked with I understood the processes I
know how to get things done I understood
our technology portfolio I could take
some of my experiences in one area and
move it to the other and then all of a
sudden I had a network of people I could
reach out to so in development suddenly
we had this technical problem and I
could call up my friends and colleagues
and former employees from my research
days and say drive up to this
development lab we need your help and
and so on so I think that there were
sort of intangible benefits of being at
the same company even though I had the
chance to do all these different things
I was deliberate about going after doing
different things though I mean I I I
would say there are there are not just a
few people who come to IBM research and
stay at IBM research and it's a large
3,000 researchers it's a large community
but there are 280,000 people at the
company so it's a much larger company
and it was the most surprising change PE
people said to me was why are you
leaving research how and I'd been there
about six years and I made a deliberate
choice to go learn about what the rest
of the company and that's what allowed
me to keep learning and keep having
these different experiences which for me
me was what kind of kept it
interesting great um if can I sound you
out on one last topic before we adjourn
um you mentioned one of your blog posts
was about what it's like to be a woman
in a sort of male dominated Technology
field and I just wonder if you could you
know give us a sense of that and some
pointers perhaps for folks in our
audience yeah there's no easy answers
unfortunately not enough has changed in
my opinion um it was n so unusual when I
was back at Yale to be among a few of
the women in Applied Physics classes or
in engineering classes and that
continued in my PhD program at Stanford
that continued when I joined IBM
research there was never a line at the
women's bathroom so there's benefits um
that continued when I moved into
Hardware development right move working
in the semiconductor World working in
the systems development and then even in
the product management side of that
Hardware so so Hardware tends still to
be less diverse than other other aspects
of engineering and and applied science
so my disappointment is that not enough
has changed in the last 30 years as I
would have hoped um I think the good
news is I think there's a lot more
awareness that we need
to uh tap into a larger segment of our
population for a lot of the important
innovation and opportunities that
they're they're lucrative jobs there
exciting challenges we want all diverse
perspective there's so many good reasons
there's truly a business imperative not
just it's the right thing to do uh but
again we're we're we're still not seeing
such a dramatic change um I didn't
experience overt discrimination or bias
I really didn't I I were there were
times where I felt awkward or I felt um
you know just disappointed that I was
the only woman in the room and some
sometimes I was the leader in the room
as the only woman which can again feel a
little bit I'd say uncomfortable but you
get used to it I'd say a little bit over
time um my experience is just to not be
afraid to speak up when um I need to
even if that takes takes a little bit of
practice and then speak up for others as
well right if when I see that there are
women that maybe are sitting not at the
table or are not being heard or you know
stereotypically but actually in practice
I have seen plenty of times where a
woman will say something and it's not
really recognized and a man will repeat
it and everyone says oh what a good
idea and I will often say U we heard
that five minutes ago if it was that
kind of idea let's make sure we go back
to so and so and hear what what other
ideas she has so I think it it's on all
of us but particularly for those who are
in leadership positions to look out for
for circumstances where traditionally
the woman gets asked to take the notes
or send out the agenda or do the things
that are the extra work when that's
reasonable sometimes but that those
sorts of responsibilities should be
passed around so as a leader I think
there's more we can all do to call that
out and then help to move things forward
in a in a positive
way good well Katherine thank you so
much for being here with us today you're
tribute to Yale and uh we're very
pleased you're able to share your story
with us here uh and thank you all for
coming look forward to more Dean
lectures in the future join us
[Music]
again